les deux hommes ont tout simplement
campé sur leurs positions initiales jo
baden par une succession de formule
plutôt évasive d'ailleurs s'est posé en
défenseur de l'intégrité territoriale et
de l'indépendance de l'ukraine face à ce
qu'il a qualifié de menace russe les
mots sont sombres sont lourds mais des
menaces évasive encore une fois
puisqu'en réalité quand joe biden
affirme qu'il ne laissera pas faire
vladimir poutine si celui-ci se lancer
dans une opération d'invasion de
l'ukraine comme cela est clairement
redouté depuis des mois déjà par le
pentagone et toutes les chancelleries
occidentales
joe biden affirme qu'il ne laissera pas
fait recette cette invasion mais cela ne
signifie pas du tout que les états unis
s'opposeront militairement la russie il
y a d'ailleurs bien longtemps plusieurs
mois que joe biden a annoncé que cela le
serait tout simplement pas le cas pour
cela et même si ça n'a pas été
directement formulée par le président
américain il y a les pays de l'union
européenne membres de l'otan et qui se
trouve concrètement en première ligne au
sens propre joe biden lui n'envisage que
des sanctions de type économique vous
l'avez dit tout en étant proprement
incapable de décrire ces sanctions
autrement qu'en employant des
superlatifs de son côté vladimir poutine
a pu formuler des propos plutôt
rassurant rappelant que son intention
n'était pas une attaque frontale de
l'ukraine mais le numéro un russe a
courtoisement mis en garde le président
vous l'avez rappelé en lui rappelant
qu'il était proprement hors de question
que ces pays qui autrefois était saoul
influence de l'union soviétique viennent
grossir les rangs de l'organisation
transatlantique c'est une obsession pour
vladimir poutine or vous le savez ces
dernières décennies les obsessions de la
dîmière poutine ont plutôt eu tendance à
se transformer en réalité